the world is in turmoil the way the
world works has been turned on its head
billions are being spent to keep the
world economy afloat and around the
globe millions of people are facing an
uncertain future but out of crisis comes
perhaps an opportunity to rebuild
something better well tonight on sky
news are working life after the pandemic
and a new world
[Music]
a very good evening I'm Dermot Murnaghan
now over the course of this week I'm
speaking there's some of the leading
lights in the worlds of culture politics
science and tonight economics joining us
a live virtual studio audience from all
around the world who will be asking
questions about how we can build a new
future and I say from around the world
they're from Mexico Ghana Italy Spain
Greece Argentina and of course the
United Kingdom now facing them we have a
Nobel prize-winning economist professor
Joseph Stiglitz the former chief
executive of BP nor Braun we also have
the economist stephanie kelton a former
advisor to the u.s. Democratic Party and
joining them Stephen Moore a member of
President trumps coronavirus task force
for the economy welcome to you all
so with jobs finance and economics now
under a strain not felt for many
generations tonight we look at the
future for the economy and the world of
work I was empty mister people as far as
the eye can see
[Music]
I'm critical-care nurse I've just
finished fortunately I was at work
there's no free there's no vegetables
over here
consider the impact they're stocking up
might have on others
this is Regent Street home to some of
the biggest names in retail and it's
almost deserted
they're talking about the economy
contracting by 35% that would be the
biggest quarterly for we've ever seen
the UK is facing a significant recession
British Airways are set to make up to
12,000 workers redundant Virgin Atlantic
Airways is to cut more than 3,000 jobs
today
maybe it's shortly being put into
administration unique in modern times
we've never seen anything like this for
the first time in our history the
government is going to step in and help
to pay people as wages f1 cars are out
ventilator trolleys are in the sheer
scale and speed of what's happening here
is clearly a triumph you feel so much
more protective we are see the
indomitable spirit of Britain the
estate's online sales are up nearly
2,000 percent there are some fantastic
ideas out there where if we ever get
over this the world has to change well
we get in families audio indirect to the
house people have started cooking again
but I do think that they're British
tourism industry is gonna hit the roof
now won't be just going back it will be
a new normal
[Music]
there we have the changing way that our
world is working so let's dive in go
straight to our virtual audience
gathered from all corners of the globe
and our first question tonight that
comes from Alex Liberto who's in Rome a
very good evening to you Alex what would
you like to ask our panel to kick us off
good evening
yes a friend of mine who was a
successful businessman told me that in
hindsight he would have preferred to
risk dying from the virus rather than to
suffer the trauma trepidation and
degradation of certain poverty he now
faces so my question is how can
politicians and scientists come together
to balance this rock and a hard place
situation considering that the effort so
far have only caused personal and social
economic devastation well that really is
quite a first question thank you very
much indeed for that Alex well let's put
it straight away to our panel very good
evening to you all once again and if I
can start with you then professor
Stiglitz the issue I suppose is is
locked down and all its consequences an
economic price worth paying
oh I think it's inevitable even if we
didn't have the lock down people would
be so scared of the pandemic that
they're not going to be by going to the
theater they're not going to be buying
locks of goods so we would have even
without the lock down have had a serious
economic downturn and without the lock
down that contagious the contagion of
the disease would be much worse and the
perpetuation of the disease would be
much worse and so over the long run I
think we would suffer more the countries
like New Zealand that put in place good
economic policies and good health
policies are have been able to mitigate
the adverse economic effects and have
put the pandemic under control Stephen
nor can I bring you in here and ask you
your view on that did this have to be
done did they have to be almost global
towns with a few exceptions well I can
really only talk about the United States
but I think that what has happened over
the last two or three months in the
United States will go down in history as
one of the greatest economic tragedies
and one of the most biggest political
blunders of our time we knew at the time
that there were about 13 or 15 major
cities that had been impacted by
coronavirus we also knew from what was
happening in China and Korea that what
we all know now to be absolutely true
that this is an old person's disease
that people who had pre-existing
conditions and people who were over the
age of 65 were quite vulnerable but
young we now know that young people are
not vulnerable to this disease so we
made huge multitrillion-dollar mistakes
here I agree with George Stigler that
there would have been a huge impact on
the economy no question about it if we
had acted differently but the idea of
shutting down our economy was a
catastrophic decision not just for our
economy but the health effects of the
coronavirus shut down and lock down have
been arguably worse than what would have
happened if we simply let people make
their own decisions about whether to go
out and I make one other point we are
you you all know that we're seeing these
horrendous riots around the United
States in major cities these are these
riots are a direct result of the
lockdown you can't keep the American
people especially young people locked in
their homes for two or three months and
expect anything but this and so I think
that the the kind of chaos we're seeing
in American cities is a direct result of
a very faulty policy of locking people
in their homes
professor Stiglitz just a quick
rejoinder to that before I bring in our
other two panelists I just have to
respond very strongly the protests in
the United States are a result of police
brutality 50 years of police brutality
in fact 150 years of police brutality it
is a result of a kind of brutality that
has been flamed inflamed by president
Trump's diss just rhetoric and that is
the reason that we our country is
burning today
okay well I'm gonna bring as I say our
other two panelists in a moment or two
on that already a very polarized views
but I want to ask our audience want to
put a straw poll to our audience by a
show of hands if you would and we
hearing there one of our panelists
thinks it's lockdown is a blunder
another think of course it has to be had
to be done so here's my question to you
do you think the cure in the shape of
the economic lockdown could prove worse
than the disease itself hands up if you
think the lockdown is worse than the
virus well that is just a handful I'd
say what three or four another question
for you then audience I'm just jotting
that down hands up if you think the
government's have generally that have
done it that if you think that
governments have generally lifted
lockdown too soon hands up if you think
governments have generally lifted or
started lifting their lockdowns too soon
what do you think about that I'm saying
two-thirds to three-quarters of our
straw poll there well thank you very
much indeed for that so let's get
straight back to our panelists there and
Lord Browne so we have people laying
down their their livelihoods and their
jobs so that others can live but
according to our panelists that is a
price worth paying
but and I agree is a price worth paying
to maintain the health of the vast
majority of people whether this locked
out but rather than look at what could
have been I think we are where we are
and actually we're learning a lot of
we're changing a lot for the future
probably for the best I can only speak
from the point of view of business but
business is learning about different
ways of doing business more efficient
more localized more national there's
more in tracked more accelerated
activity to make to make business more
intelligent there's there's a real
understanding perhaps
Nature has been a very big force here a
very big force we don't want that to
happen again and so climate change is on
the agenda are still probably reinforced
something must be done to keep the
environment to keep us healthy so there
are many things that I think are
happening here that will change the way
we think about the future and that is
very important because I think we
probably couldn't have gone on the way
we were going before the virus and to be
explored a lot more deeply or during the
course of this next hour but stephanie
kelton all that that strawpoll from our
audience there about three or four of
them thinking that the lockdown was not
a price worth paying but three quarters
of them thinking that lockdown has been
lifted too soon your thoughts on that
and more broadly well my first thought
is that I agree completely with
Professor Stiglitz that the lockdown
itself is not what ultimately led
consumers to withdraw from economic
activity in in a huge way it was fear of
the virus itself who was fear of
contracting a very contagious and lethal
virus and people would have withdrawn
independent of governor's or other
public officials asking them to shelter
in place in socially distance and so
forth so look I think that what we have
now is a situation where we're we're
starting to open things up and there is
a safe way to do that and the scientists
are telling us how to safely reopen this
economy and what it really requires is a
great deal of testing contact tracing
isolating people when they become
infected we know what needs to be done
we're just not executing well and we're
not anywhere near the level of testing
that we need to safely begin to reopen
the economy and so once again it is us
versus the virus and consumer psychology
plays the overwhelming kind of driving
force in all of this if people don't
feel safe they're not going to re-engage
fully with the economy
they're not going to go back into
restaurants and bars and theaters and so
we are at a stage now where in a very
real sense it's in our hands to
determine the pace of this recovery how
quickly we can get back to you know
engaging with the economy in a in a way
that's familiar to us but until enough
people feel safe going back and Riaan
gauging I think you're going to continue
to see an economy that struggles to
recover
okay well let's broaden this out a bit
because we've been conducting a
wide-ranging opinion poll for these
programs about the future facing the
world and it revealed some really
striking insights into what the British
public wants to change now this is what
we asked people we asked them to
consider the types of jobs people do and
the different things that British
companies sell and invest in let me take
you through some of these significant
results and we asked once the outbreak
is over how should the British economy
be structured now a quarter of people
precisely that 25 percent said they
believe the economy should go back to
being much the same as it was before as
I say a quarter but more than double
that 57% said they thought the economy
should be significantly different to
before and you know what one of our
studio audience has a question that
relates directly to that he's Jeremy
Baker from London Jeremy can you put
your question to the panel for us please
and a very good evening to you hi
isn't this a perfect opportunity for us
to jump straight into the new modern
Britain say goodbye to the past I'm very
worried that Vichy sunic is spending our
money on old companies and old drugs
well there we are a lot to take in there
in a fairly short question from Jeremy
Baker and taking on board our poll as
well and Lord Browne then you were
touching on it already
57% of those polled said they thought
the economy should be and would be
significantly different to before how
can it be or changing economies takes a
a lot of time and effort but I think
again before the pandemic struck there
were some things going on which I think
now will be
generated the first was to heavily
invest in innovation in smaller
companies doing a lot of R&D the
government was going to and I still
think will increase the amount of state
spending on R&D by 50 percent and that
would mean business will follow that at
least at that level if not double that
and so there's a lot of things going on
which right the future we can't go on
just investing in own companies we have
in this economy far too much
concentration for example in aerospace
and automotive a lot of the developments
for the future were taking place they
have now been cruelly shut down so we
need to diversify we need to change the
way in which we apply things if I may
say so I think in this this economy
we're great at innovating and
discovering things the science and
engineering we're not very good at
retaining the companies here we have a
wonderful track record in artificial
intelligence for example but of the four
great companies that we invented here
they all went back to him they went to
American investors and to America but of
course they need to change yeah I mean
but the change all takes time and
addressing Jeremy's question directly
stephanie kelton in effect he's saying
all these furlough schemes these job
retention schemes some of them we don't
know how many yet some of them are
zombie jobs there will be no real work
to go back to well I think he's right I
mean you know the the reality of the
situation is that a large number of
industries may permanently shrink a lot
of the small businesses that we are
helping today may not make it on the
other side in fact we know that they
want maybe as many as half of them won't
be viable on the other side of this but
what is what do you do in the immediate
term when you've got tens of millions of
people whose livelihoods are tied to
their jobs
there is a way to get immediate aid to
those individuals you can't know in
advance which companies are going to be
successful and which won't make it on
the other side and in a crisis speed is
everything so what the government did I
think was the right thing to try to help
companies hold things together to keep
employees on payroll to help these small
businesses meet their recurring expenses
try to help them remain viable so that
if you know we get through this then we
maybe end up with fewer failed companies
but the reality is that some of the
bigger industries are going to
permanently change and you know the the
benefit is that we will have time in the
months and years ahead
to begin to think about how to make
strategic investments and in which
industries to support but in the short
term time is everything and getting the
money out really was critically
important to try to containing the
collateral damage well Steven well what
do you think about that the the
government's role with stephanie kelton
touched on there in choosing the jobs of
the future and what do you think they're
gonna be well that's the whole point is
none of us know what those industries of
the future will be a good example is you
know for the last ten years the United
States of America went through the
greatest oil and gas boom in the history
of this country and we became the energy
powerhouse nation nobody in government
predicted that would happen in fact you
know in the midst of it Barack Obama
said we were gonna you know we were
gonna dig for the last barrel of oil in
the United States and in the midst of
this boom so my point is politicians
don't know what the next industry is the
people who know that and we're going to
make the right decisions our private
investors we've made a lot of really
really bad decisions over the last
couple of months
for example in the United States I can't
speak for other countries we started
paying people as much or more in fact in
31 States now out of the 50 in the
United States people are paid more money
to stay unemployed than to go on a job
now you don't have to be an economist to
understand that's a really stupid thing
to do and now we have a big big problem
in terms of getting we do have our
business
is back starting to revive themselves
especially in the red states of america
with republican governors that are up
and running and that's a good news and
they're by the way they're doing it in a
way that's actually keeping people safe
and healthy but what's so interesting
about this is that you've got these
states now that are up and running but
in the businesses are starting to hire
again we have the strange situation
we're up about thirty five million
people unemployed in the united states
but businesses can't get people back on
the job because of stupid government
policies that are paying them to stay
unemployed so joseph stiglitz do we have
to pull the rug then on these jobs
support schemes or indeed keep them
going I mean let the market decide oh
let's be clear the reason people don't
want it back to work is they don't like
get the disease and the government
agency that's supposed to protect people
which the United States is called OSHA
health and safety the workers has under
the trump administration been asleep it
didn't require people to have protective
gear didn't provide mass didn't provide
tests and that's why people are afraid
to go to work it's just very simple if
you if your choices work or dying people
who would rather not die it was
absolutely essential that we provide
assistance now the way that money has
been administered by the Trump
administration and the legislation that
was adopted was not the best designed
you contrast the programs that were
enacted in several of the European
countries in New Zealand where they said
let's keep the connection between
employees and their firms let's keep
that going so that when we do recover
that connection we'll be there and we
can start up the economy that was the
idea and most of these other countries
succeeded UK had something like that and
succeeded the United States is number
one in unemployment number one in
disease number one in deaths and that's
all because of failed policies
the policy we're talking about here is
the failure to design a program that
would provide income to ordinary
individuals and keep them at the same
time connected with their employer
particularly important in this pandemic
because most Americans rely on health
insurance provided by the employer not
like other civilized countries we don't
recognize in the United States the right
of access to health care and in the last
three years life expectancy is already
down and without health insurance it's
going to get even worse
okay well plenty more to continue with I
want to go back to our exclusive after
the pandemic poll something it tells us
about the economic priorities of the
public we asked people to spend a moment
thinking about the money the government
has borrowed during the course of the
outbreak now here's what we found 49%
said they thought ministers should
maintain spending even if that meant the
amount of borrowing and the national
debt grew larger that's against 20
percent who said they believe the
government should reduce borrowing and
attempt to balance the budget so 49
percent nearly half saying maintain this
spending 20 percent saying reduce the
borrowing so more than 2 to 1 in favor
of continuing the spending Stephen Moore
well I just had a piece in The Wall
Street Journal yesterday showing that if
we continue to spend it the way we're
doing in the United States for the first
time in American history government
spending at all levels will be higher
than our private sector that is a very
scary thing for the land of the free a
country that is supposed to believe in
free markets and and you know if you
have the government now larger than the
entire production of private enterprise
and and a private worker output that
that means that this is this is more
than Bernie Sanders could have ever
imagined so we have to stop the spending
what I have proposed and out laugh or
another economist is to suspend the
payroll tax
that's imposed on every worker in
America and every small business in
America as a way to get people back to
work and by the way the professor's just
wrong on this
professor people under the age of 35 are
not vulnerable to the to the coronavirus
that's the one lesson we've learned that
two-thirds of the dusts have been people
in nursing homes in the last year of
their life so there's been a scare
campaign by the media that has not
informed people what's really happening
we didn't know that eight weeks ago we
do know that now that we have to keep
our seniors safe
the governor is like Andrew Cuomo did
not keep their nursing home safe and
they're responsible for thousands of
lives but young people can return to the
job they do want to return the job and
that should be their choice they should
make that if they're if they don't feel
safe to go back to the job they
shouldn't have to but I guarantee you
there are tens of millions of Americans
who want to get back on the job and they
can do so safely well stephanie kelton
take that on board as well along with
the continued the spending there's a lot
of science here coming up from that
position as well a lot of medicine as
well let the young people out they can
kick-start the economy all right so we
continue to say that until people feel
safe they are not going to re-engage
with the economy I think that is the
correct thing to say this virus does not
discriminate yes
some age demographics get more heavily
hit but frontline workers overwhelmingly
younger people also contracted this
virus so we're still learning a lot
about this virus we're learning that it
infects the blood system the blood
vessels and so we don't yet know exactly
who the vulnerable population is but one
life is too many to take risks and
chances and say oh well these people
were almost at the death's door anyway
so what what difference does it make
let's carry on with the economic
activity and let the old folks just fall
away that's awful
okay look on this point about the
payroll tax and this idea that the way
that we're going to restart the economy
is by cutting payroll taxes
is almost as if the Republican Party and
Stephen who helps to advise this party
manages in every possible situation to
find a way to get money to the people
who least need the help you're talking
about a payroll tax holiday which means
you want to cut taxes for people who are
on payroll who are employed what we're
worried about are the 40 million people
who have already lost their jobs they've
lost their income and to the extent that
they go back into the workplace it's
because we allow their unemployment
insurance to expire we didn't extend it
they don't have alternatives they've got
to meet rent they've got to buy food
they have to pay bills and they're gonna
be forced back into an economy that is a
dangerous environment with a pandemic
that is still raging why because we are
not anywhere close to doing the testing
we ought to be doing at this stage we
need to be testing about 23 million
people a day we are nowhere near that so
we're telling people to go back out
where it's dangerous and work and
produce and they will have no
alternative okay we've got a question on
that topic on taxes coming up we have a
question from Nadine Achmed from West
London about the impact the government's
actions and the furlough scheme in
particular might have and a Dean please
show you a question with us hi good
evening dumat good evening panel good
afternoon panel and basically given that
we will be in a recession after the
pandemics finished what taxes might the
government consider to cover for the
costs of the phonus schemes
okay taxes will they have to go up can I
just ask you while you with us Nadeem
have you been furloughed or have you
lost your job or anything like that yeah
I've lost my job due to the pandemic it
did impact the business so I'm one of
those unfortunate ones and yes so
principies why my question I think I've
prolonged that is a question that's been
addressed elsewhere but that was my main
concern see what we do with that
okay the costs involved in all this will
taxes have to rise well thank you very
much indeed for that an edema should say
one of our panelists Stephen Moore has
had to go and his advisory role we are
told he has to take a call from the
White House he will be back to rejoin us
some perhaps you might share with
what discussions he has had given what's
going on in the United States at the
moment but let's ask about taxes and
costs and we've been talking about tax
cuts to stimulate the economy law Brown
which way do you think it should go in
the UK as it tries to recover with this
huge amount of spending huge amount of
debt being a cruder a huge deficit
building 300 billion plus perhaps in
this year should taxes rise as a result
I expect taxes will rise as a result
it's a practical matter I do think
several other things will happen first
is I it's very clear that the government
will end up owning pieces of companies
and they have to decide what to do not
to drive them as bureaucracies but to
drive them in an enlightened ways that
they can expand and flourish when they
come out of care as they are at the
moment secondly I do think taxes will
rise and that would be expected and
thirdly debt levels I think will stay
high for some time until we can get back
on a growth track so we have to be very
careful I think we will probably have an
attitude of make-do in many areas we
will probably expand investment in other
areas which will increase jobs which add
the cost of investment as a pressed of
revenue expenditure from the government
as well as business do you think taxes
should ride rise or just will have to
rise well I think from a business
perspective it would make sense but I
think looking at all those people have
been furloughed they probably should
have to shoulder some of those I mean
you've got to remember not everybody's
been thrown out so it'd be very unfair
for those to have to pay taxes to an
extent to cover the cost especially if
they have never taken anything from the
government I mean I think maybe it needs
to be looked at in a fair way perhaps
Joseph Stiglitz on the overall borrowing
and spending and and the tax approach um
eight trillion I saw today is the
Congressional estimate and what the
United States is going to have to borrow
print or find over the next ten years to
pay for all this eight trillion dollars
well first let me say that the debt
itself is not going to be a much of a
problem because we're likely to see a
very weak economy interest rates are
going to be very low all the word
forecasts are for very low interest
rates as far as the eye can see the
market says this so if interest rates
are close to zero the cost of the debt
servicing the debt is close to zero so
I'm not worried about the debt for the
immediate future and to echo what was
said before though
worries about the debt should not
inhibit us from doing what we need to do
to protect the vulnerable and
resuscitate the economy now at the same
time there is room for increased
taxation more room in the United States
than in the UK but for instance I'm sure
we're around will agree on this we have
to redirect our economy to the economy
the future in one area of that economy
the future is a greener economy
so environmental taxes would have a
double benefit it would raise revenue
and they would steer the economy towards
a better economy to a greener economy
and you can do this in a way that our
distributionally beneficial a second
example in the United States the
corporations are not paying their fair
share of taxes they were and and we know
that we have many corporations with a
lot of monopoly power and they're making
their returns not from innovation but
it's from the exploitation of monopoly
power and if you can tap some of that
monopoly power
huge sources
revenues that we could use and in the
United States the people at the top the
very richest are actually paying a lower
tax than people down below so we up a
regressive tax system if we just had a
fair tax system we would have a lot more
tax revenue the same thing is true to a
lesser extent in the UK Stephani Council
I'm sure you agree with an awful lot of
that but as I say eight trillion dollars
or more just for the United States sure
the United States can either borrow or
print it but ultimately won't that be
inflationary you just hit on the
critical point I mean that is the
relevant limit so if we are looking at
an economy that is depressed and that is
likely to remain depressed for years to
come in fact just yesterday here in the
United States the Congressional Budget
Office released a report saying that
they anticipate now that the United
States economy is going to sacrifice the
equivalent of about 16 trillion dollars
in lost output over the course of the
next 10 years why because they expect
that the ring that the economic recovery
is going to be very sluggish that they
were not going to operate our economy at
full employment in other words we're
gonna have depressed conditions for a
very long period of time what that means
is that there is room in the economy for
the federal government to provide
continued support in the form of fiscal
policy that fiscal support can eat up
some of that slack in the economy and
help move us to a more robust recovery
and quicker return to full employment so
I'm not preoccupied with the size of the
deficit or the impacts on the debt what
I care about is what you just mentioned
the inflation risk if we try to drive
things too fast too far the punishment
is not going to be in solvency for the
federal government it's not going to be
that we wreck our finances it's going to
be that we cause inflation to accelerate
I don't think we're anywhere new
facing that kind of a risk I think the
much greater risk is that we do too
little not too much and we end up with
double-digit unemployment for a
prolonged period of time and an economy
that continues to fall well short of
full employment
okay so inflation not a risk in your
estimation at the moment listen time for
another question from our virtual
audience and I know it's a specific one
that Phil docking who joins us from
Crete very good evening to you Phil and
what would you like to hear me well
given the predictions that the job
market will contract drastically after
the pandemic isn't it time to ditch the
capitalism light model of full
employment and start working on more
progressive economic policies such as
universal basic income
aah-ha universal basic income I wondered
when that might come up from Phil there
Joseph Stiglitz nodding along there well
for the uninitiated like most of us what
is it how does it work I know it's been
tried out in some countries in some
areas just explain the bones of this
policy what universal basic income says
you'll give money to everybody universal
a basic level that allows them to
survive and it says not me
testa you don't have application forms
you don't have to go through a
bureaucracy everybody gets it well I'm
not basically I'm not a big fan of
universal basic income and the reason
for that is very simple right now and
for the next 15 20 25 years we have an
enormous amount of things that need to
be done we have to finance the green
transition we have huge deficiencies and
in our infrastructure there are people
who need health care we have a large
number of jobs that need to be done and
we have people who want to work that
mismatch is the feeling of our market
economy today and what we need to do is
to say
everybody who wants a job and is able to
get it to work ought to have a job that
was the commitment in the United States
what we made in the full employment Act
of 1948 and that should be our primary
commitment today and it's exactly what
Stephanie is saying there are lots of
people want to work there's dignity
associated with work and our failure is
not to have our economic system provide
that work given all the things that need
to be done today
okay so jobs not free money not a
universal basic income and your
estimation there professor let's see if
our audience agree with you another
straw poll if you would very much
appreciate this let me ask you about the
universal basic income how many of you
would like to see a change in the way
the economy works put your hands up if
you would supports a universal basic
income now you know how it works after
listening to Professor Stiglitz and let
me add the rider in there even if it
meant a significant increase in taxes so
here's the question hands up if you
would support a universal basic income
even if it meant a significant increase
in taxes mm-hmm
well well 80 percent disagreeing perhaps
with Joseph Stiglitz and Lord Brown let
me ask you isn't it then a disincentive
to work if you've got just enough to
live on being given to you by the state
why would you work well part of it is I
think it's founded in dignity I think
people do actually want to work in the
large bulk but it's right that there
should be not disincentives since it's
crazy of people earn more money by not
working rather than actually working so
we need to think very carefully and we
peni I think the nations have moved from
you know basic minimum wage to a living
wage and and there are progressive
changes here which I think we shouldn't
stand in the way of I mean there be more
changes yes absolutely right we've got
tons of things
we need people in work we need them
trained in the right way but to get the
economy to be really green to get net
zero emissions we need brand new jobs I
think in health care we've seen probably
a lack of people who do one thing that
only humans can do which is to give
people empathy probably we need more
workers in this particular area and then
as to infrastructure there's so much of
it that needs replacing for a modern
economy that there's a huge amount to do
there so I think that there's a lot
which has to be done we need to
encourage and inspire people to want to
have these jobs and stephanie kelton
just your view on the universal basic
income
well you said before professor Stiglitz
said that it should be about jobs but
don't we then end up with work creation
schemes governments paying people to dig
holes and fill them in again no you and
what you end up with I think in in a
properly run public service employment
or job guarantee program are the local
communities themselves engaging in the
process and deciding what they value and
the kind of work that would be the most
meaningful add the most value to their
lives in their community so what you
might imagine is a program that is
federally funded but highly
decentralized locally administered so
that people in I'll use the US case in
northeastern Oklahoma know best what the
needs of that community are the federal
government does not but the federal
government can provide the funding so
that people can be hired and employed we
did this out in the New Deal era we had
the Works Progress Administration we had
the Civilian Conservation Corps we had a
jobs program for young people called the
National Youth administration so FDR
rolled out a whole alphabet soup of
public job programs and we could
seriously consider modeling job programs
today on something like that it wouldn't
preclude a basic income as
Martin Luther King jr. said and other
civil rights leaders they said there
should be a basic income for those who
cannot or should not work and so we can
just decide as a society who falls into
those categories of you know people that
should not be in the in the workforce
but there ought to be a way for those
who want to work to have employment if
they choose it and can't find it
anywhere else in the economy as joe said
there is a great deal of work as both of
them said there is plenty of work that
needs to be done okay well I'm glad to
say that Stephen Moore is back with us
after doing a bit of work with the white
house want your views on a universal
basic income and of course what you were
hearing there about an FDR type New Deal
for the 21st century but can you share
with the surfy back to us any of your
discussions with your White House
colleagues well I would but I'd have to
kill you you know I was very proud to
work with the president in an honest
campaign as an economic advice or we put
together a plan that cut taxes on our
businesses to make America more
competitive we slashed regulations we
put in place new trade deals that made
America more competitive and that worked
more to America's advantage it create we
created the best economy in 30 or 40
years we had a three and a half percent
unemployment rate until the coronavirus
hit we had six million surplus jobs I
hear you all talking about that gee how
do we create jobs Donald Trump did it we
had the best you know we had Y rising
wages for every income group minority
saw the biggest increases in wages it
was a beautiful thing the best economy
and we so how do we rebuild the economy
we do exactly what we were doing before
we reduce taxes we do reduce regulations
and red tape that that are onerous on
businesses and we we have good trade
deals and by the way a big part of that
is our energy policy you know the idea
that we're going to give up our oil and
gas and coal is ridiculous those are
major sectors of our economy but we do
know how to create jobs we did a great
job of it and that's gonna be really
what this election coming up in November
is going to be about do you
want to do you want to create the kind
of economy that we had under Donald
Trump before the coronavirus hit where
68% of Americans felt like the economy
was going in the right direction and I
would would just say one other thing
this is an international audience folks
it is not complicated reduce your taxes
on your businesses reward them by
reducing regulations that don't make
sense do things that are in making your
own economies and businesses more
competitive and get the government the
hell out of the way that's what Donald
Trump I think where did it work thank
you very much indeed for that now the
other panelists are taking a radically
different view on that than you now
we've got a very important question
coming up I know but I just want a very
briefly if you would to the other three
of you address that issue tax cuts and
allow the market and entrepreneurs to
shape the future economy stephanie
kelton look we know what happened with
these tax cuts the way the personal
income tax cuts were structured in the
tax cuts that were passed at the end of
2017 83% of the benefits went to people
in the top 1% of the income distribution
this is simply funneling a windfall to
the people who least need the help on
the corporate side you say cut taxes for
your business and this is how to rein
jobs down on the rest of the economy but
we know that business is overwhelmingly
took those windfalls and did what
mergers and acquisitions and stock
buybacks they did not raise wages they
did not increase hiring so especially in
an environment like this the way to
incentivize businesses to hire people
back is to swamp them with customers and
the way to swamp them with customers is
to build robust increases in people's
incomes jobs incomes create consumers
who create demand who create jobs but
know Brown don't tax cuts put money in
people's pockets and create demand it
depends how they're done and I think I'm
all in favor of incentives for business
that create opportunities and actually
create investment I think that is really
very important
because that's about the future so I
think that's essential I also think that
while regulations can be misplaced
equally I think a totally free corporate
sector would not be a sector I'd want it
is something that has to be contained by
the interest of all stakeholders not
just investors but also employees and
the communities and be and the people
who don't have a voice the environment
and so forth so I think that I don't to
buy a package of total liberalisation
about a package of balanced activity if
tax cuts lead to better in really better
investment and so far they have not done
that in the United States then I think
it would be a great thing to have okay
listen we've got some we are indeed
beginning to run out of time so we've
got a very important question is saya
coming up from one of our virtual
audience this is from amber curry in
Oxfordshire
please far away amber as a recent
graduate I'm worried about how I can
enter an industry that is so reliant on
face-to-face contact I have to find my
masters as a result of code at 19 but
will I be able to gain industry
experience in the meantime thank you
thank you very much indeed for that
amber very important to joseph stiglitz
we touched on this already but let's
address it directly this crisis is
generational it's young people who are
not getting training not going to get
jobs to save older people that's what
the statistics tell us about coronavirus
sorry professor
Stiglitz I wondered if you could still
hear me the question about the
generational divide yes we've had a
generational divide exactly been going
on for a long time the one of the
problems is that wages have been
stagnant and this has been particularly
true in recent years and part of the
reason is unfettered capitalism hasn't
been working for ordinary individuals at
the bottom the wages in the United
States for instance are the same as they
were 60 years ago median income people
income in the middle has been stagnating
so in fact the market has created this
divide between the young people and they
oh they can't buy houses they're left
with huge amounts of student debt to go
to school in the United States over one
and a half trillion dollars now the
question that you asked is what about
the jobs and it seems to me that what we
need to do in the face of the pandemic
is to say every young person
should either be in a job in school or
in some kind of a training program and
the pandemic will be over eventually
I feel confident of that and the
question is what is going to happen in
the next two or three years are you are
the years going to be wasted or can you
get some skills that will provide you
with a better opportunities in the post
pandemic world and that's what we need
to be focusing on right now stephanie
kelton we've touched on this a little
bit earlier as well and can I ask you
what we're seeing on the streets of so
many American cities at the moment yes
of course sparked by a racist killing
but we're seeing many many young people
in particular this unemployment there's
inequality rife in the United States and
indeed countries like the one I'm in at
the moment is this perhaps one of the
outcomes that we could continue to see
from this crisis I mean people in
distress will take to the streets and
let you know that they are in distress
so at the moment you're right what we're
seeing are a lot of protests that are
being driven by the fact that you know
we continue to see again and again and
again in this country police officers
taking the lives of African Americans
murdering them on the streets we see
these images all the time it's festering
it's coming with the backdrop of Kovan
19:00 where we're all uniquely keenly
aware of the fact that the frontline
workers who bore disproportionately
either the pain associated with job
losses income losses and so forth of
people of color so we see the inequities
we see how unfair this is what you have
are blacks and whites and Latinos and
Asian's Americans and Native people are
coming together to say this is in just
all of it not just the killings but the
whole of the system is rotten and people
are saying we are not going to stand for
an economic and social system that
operates this way in the future as
even more well clearly obviously not to
be condoned but is it understandable
when what is happening on the streets of
these American cities is it
understandable is it well I think the
better question is it justifiable and I
think almost everyone agrees that this
criminal behavior has to stop and I
think President Trump is right that we
we have to stop the rioting and looting
it is outrageous
it is hurting the very people in these
communities that have been afflicted by
you know with low incomes and so on so
it's a horrible thing it's a horrible
thing we're seeing in these in these in
these cities and and frankly I think
Americans are sick and tired of people
apologizing for really radical behavior
that as I said is hurting these very
people who are supposed to be supposed
to be you know benefiting from this now
look we have to America's right now we
have an America of red states that's
what's kind of unique about the United
States that the states really do run the
show and we have red states like Georgia
and Florida and Texas and Tennessee that
are booming
absolutely booming have had twice the
rate of growth and twice the rate of job
creation in the last 20 years and then
you have these states like New York and
Connecticut New Jersey in my home state
of Illinois and other states that are
run by Democrats that have been running
to the ground and those are the places
where the riots have been worse so why
don't we use the policies that were
lower taxes lower wrecked oh I'm not
saying we shouldn't have any regulations
I'm saying we should reward our
businesses for hiring people in doing a
great job and expanding and and look we
had a great economy two-and-a-half
months ago we there was no unemployment
there were six million surplus jobs in
this country it was the best labor
market we ever had we've got to get back
to those policies but no we can never
justify violence and we can never
justify people burning down buildings
and and you know spray-painting
obscenities on churches that's a week we
can't tolerate because no one's
justifying you know the question was if
we can understand the forces that
they're driving it I just want to bring
amber back in there because amber I saw
you reacting to that and I don't know
what your thoughts were so so share them
with us what you're hearing there
I just think there the issue really and
I can't speak as I'm not an American but
it to me really seems like it's not
about looting and violence and I think
that device that needs to be stopped
it's coming more from the police rather
than any protesters okay well thank you
for that input amber and I just want to
hear from Lord Brown and you know let's
broaden this out about young people like
amber they're the seed capital of future
Society of future economies if we get
this wrong we could be in trouble
absolutely we must not get it wrong and
the problem is judging it in the middle
of the turmoil of today where there's a
lot of people without jobs because
there's not a lot of activity but again
I come back to you know building a
different world requires a lot of
different skills and that world will be
different you know just simply the
amount and changing of the way we live
and work what we're doing today on skype
for example will change the demands we
have on infrastructure for demands we
have on but how
the demands we have on all sorts of
things this will require a lot more
effort and we need young people to do
that to us in to aspire to do things to
change society to in a low-carbon world
so I think it's we need a bit of
patience we need to force absolutely the
educational and training systems to be
fit for purpose for the future and to do
this now while we have the time and I
think that is beginning to happen I'm
very struck by the fact that many
universities have said we can't teach
except face to face and they've all said
we're teaching online it's a very big
change and it says that a lot of things
can change very quickly
okay well that's I'm afraid believe it
or not almost it for tonight but before
we go I want to take a final straw poll
from our virtual
audience hello again let's work your
hands for for one more time and thank
you for your great questions by a show
of hands I want to ask you simply a you
optimistic or pessimistic about the
economic future
so the optimists please put your hands
up optimists well that's not bad that's
probably maybe maybe over a third book
just very quickly can I ask you then how
many of you have become optimists
because of what you've heard tonight
right okay but one of you if these we've
changed one mind thank you all very much
indeed so tonight we've heard arguments
in favor of a a universal basic income
the audience in favor the experts not
calls for more intervention to support
young people survive any economic
downturn and the lockdown described as
the greatest political and economic
blunder of modern times
well my thanks first of all to our
panelists tonight you know them all by
now Joseph Stiglitz Lord Brown stephanie
kelton
and stephen moore not once but twice
thank you all very much indeed and
thanks to to everyone in our virtual
studio audience getting those hands up
and down some brilliant questions thank
you for taking part those questions
really did expand our understanding I
hope and thank you at home in for
watching we've got much more to come
this week including an exclusive
interview with the Prince of Wales on
his experience of the lockdown and the
changes facing the public the country in
the world we'll bring you that on
Thursday night's more world-changing
ideas tomorrow evening and I'll be
joined by among other
one of the country's leading scientists
said Jeremy Farah that's at eight
o'clock tomorrow evening do Jonas then
if you can for now good night
[Music]